and now on book tv jesse walker talks
about his new book the united states of
paranoia in which he discusses the
popularity of political conspiracy
theories and paranoia going back to the
founding of the country this is about 45
minutes
biblical politics and prose fashion
our author events are timely
while today we present a book dealing
with an american history of conspiracies
just three days ago the cia admitted
that such a place known as area 51 does
actually exist
even though they disavow all knowledge
of any aliens
so-called conspiracy theorists rejoiced
i think they just silenced the
conspiracy theories
now the best way to sum up mr walker's
book is from page eight where he says
pundits tend to write off
political paranoia as a feature of the
french
they are wrong
the fear of conspiracies has been a
potent force
across the political spectrum from the
colonial era to the present
in
the establishment as well as at the
extremes
so all 338 of jesse's readable pages
lays out in clear often funny and as
well often surprising detail how that is
still the case
now one present day but now old
conspiracy that um i talked with mr
walker about while we was waiting that i
personally remember made its rounds
through the internet and everywhere was
the folded twenty dollar bill trick
right after nine eleven anyone familiar
with that by short hands a few folks but
everybody jesse lays it out in page 302.
um
the 20 trick
if you fold the 20 dot for folks who
don't know if you fold the 20 just the
right way it alleges to show how the
world trade the the world trade towers
are up all the blaze if you fold it up
right it supposedly has it on there
allegedly foreshadowing 911 attacks now
item for me items like that can easily
be dispelled as quackery
but um some other examples so-called
conspiracies
might take about 50 years for the real
information to come out and the truth be
exposed
speaking of truth being exposed they're
coming for me right now so jesse walker
is a books editor senior book editor at
reason magazine
university of michigan alum who's also
written rebels in the air rebels on the
air in alternative history
of radio in america back in 2001 you can
follow him on twitter twitter or on his
blog pop blog page see they coming for
me so they got me flustered the
perpetual three dot column at
jessewalker.blogspot.com
he resides right up the way in baltimore
with his wife and two daughters i now
present you
jesse walker and his second book the
united states of paranoia a conspiracy
theory
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
read a bit from the book
then i'm going to talk a bit about the
book then
then there will be a shooting
and
then i'm going to read a little bit more
from the book
and then we'll take your questions
as will the police
on january 30th everyone hear me in the
back this okay great on january 30th
1835
as andrew jackson exited a congressman's
funeral an assassin drew a weapon and
pointed it at the president
the pistol misfired
the gunman pulled a second weapon from
his cloak
though loaded it too failed to fire
the cane wielding jackson and several
bystanders subdued the would-be killer
an unemployed house painter named
richard lawrence
lawrence later informed interrogators
that he was king richard iii
that jackson had killed his father and
that with jackson dead money would be
more plenty
he was judged insane and committed to an
asylum where he died three decades later
lawrence was alone not
or at least that was the official story
it wasn't long before two witnesses
filed affidavits claiming to have seen
lawrence at the home of the mississippi
senator george poindexter shortly before
the attack
poindexter was a noisy opponent of the
jackson administration and projects in
newspapers accused the senator of
plotting the president's murder
so did jackson's allies in congress who
quickly convened an investigation
jackson himself told bystanders after
the assault that the shooter had been
hired by that damned rascal poindexter
to assassinate me
some of jackson's critics countered by
suggesting that the president had staged
the assault to gain public support and
that this explained why both weapons had
fought had failed
and many jacksonians pointed their
finger at john calhoun the south
carolina senator and former vice
president arguing that if he had not
been directly involved in the
assassination attempt he had at the very
least incited it with a speech
denouncing jackson as an american caesar
that's what they did back before they
could compare you to hitler i think
so when the republican writer john smith
died described the crime 29 years later
he saw an even more devilish plot at
work
calhoun might not have been directly
involved in the assault i conceded
whether this man was induced to attempt
induced to attempt to murder the
president by listening to his defamer
making speeches in the senate or whether
he was secretly hired to assassinate him
god alone can determine
badai believed that calhoun had been a
part of a larger force the slave power
that would have benefited if jackson had
been put in the ground and the slave
power dye informed his readers was more
than willing to kill a powerful man to
get its way
in 1841 for example president william
henry harrison told calhoun he wasn't
sure he was willing to annex texas which
southerners wanted to add to the union
as a slave state harrison promptly died
officially the cause of death was
pneumonia but dye was sure that arsenic
was to blame
nine years later die continued president
zachary taylor opposed the slave powers
agenda in cuba and the southwest and so
he was killed by the same poison
and when president-elect james buchanan
prepared to make some appointments of
which the slaveocrats disapproved dai
declared he narrowly survived one of the
most elaborate assassination plots ever
conceived
on february 23 1857 according to dye
southern agents poisoned all the bowls
containing lump sugar at the national
hotel in washington dc
southerners he explained drink coffee
coffee drinkers used pulverized sugar so
the southern diners would be spared and
the tea drinking northern diners
including buchanan would be wiped out
the future president barely survived the
illness that followed
intimidated by the attempted
assassination dye wrote buchanan became
more than ever the tool of the slave
power
and there is little evidence for dye's
explosive charges you can make a case
that harrison's doctors did more to hurt
than to help the ailing president but no
more than conjecture supports the idea
that anyone deliberately killed him
coroners debunked the belief that
zachary taylor had been poisoned when
his body was exhumed in 1991 and
buchanan was not even present in
washington on february 23rd 1857 though
dysentery did break out at the hotel
when buchanan stayed there a month
earlier and again when he returned for
his inauguration
today the outbreaks are usually
attributed to a sewage backup that
contaminated the ends food and water but
at the time several stories circulated
blaming poisoners for the illnesses with
the suspects ranging from a chinese
cabal to a band of homicidal
abolitionists
inconveniently for dye's tea and coffee
thesis the dead included a southern
congressman john quitman of mississippi
but when dye's book the adder's den was
published in 1864 the country was at war
with the south and when a new edition
appeared two years later under the title
history of the plots and crimes of the
great conspiracy to overthrow liberty in
america the nation was still reeling
from the assassination of abraham
lincoln
in that atmosphere a book that feels
like a 1970s conspiracy movie said in
the antebellum era received a respectful
notice in the new york times and was
exerted in the chicago tribune
republican papers praised it in
philadelphia harrisburg trenton and new
york city and in pennsylvania even the
democratic eastern express proclaimed it
the most powerful book of this century
nor did dye invent his theories from
nothing he drew on rumors that had been
floating through wig in republican
circles for years
after lincoln was elected well before
dye's book appeared several supporters
of the incoming president sent letters
warning him to watch out for the
plotters who had killed two of his
predecessors
general harrison lived but a short time
after he was installed in office one
concerned citizen pointed out and
general taylor lived but a short time
after he took his seat you sir be
careful at the king's table what meat
and drink you take
another letter informed lincoln that i
have often heard it stated by physicians
that it was an undoubted fact that our
last two whig presidents generals
harrison and taylor came to their sudden
and lamentable ends by subtle poisons
administered in their food at the white
house
after lincoln died at least two
prominent ministers george duffield of
detroit and william godwin of
connecticut worked the supposed murders
of harrison and taylor into their
sermons
reverend henry ward beecher not only
invoked their alleged assassinations in
an article for the new york ledger but
added the anti-secessionist democrat
stephen douglas to the list of victims
writing that he had been killed because
his position in the party made him one
of the most efficient champions against
the rebellion
uh during the effort to impeach
lincoln's southern successor a professor
president andrew johnson representative
james mitchell ashley of ohio brought up
the same old accusations declaring that
harrison taylor and buchanan had been
quote poisoned for the express purpose
of putting the vice presidents in the
presidential office
and in may 1868 an extraordinary article
in the new york tribune managed to out
die die
accusing a democratic conspiracy of
engineering the city's malaria outbreaks
after commenting that zachary taylor
fell under the malorious vapors of
washington and died because he was prone
to acting honestly and straightforward
the tribune writer
claimed that washington in subsequent
years
was free of malaria that is for
democrats but when the new republican
party began to gain strength and it was
possible that they might become the
ruling power in congress the water of
washington suddenly grew dangerous the
hotels particularly the national became
pest houses and dozens of heretics from
the democratic faith grew sick almost
unto death
the contagion of the contagions
continued until lincoln put the walls
and springs of the capital under the
care of loyal soldiers ending the
outbreaks
but after lincoln was deposed to the
pattern returned right before the vote
to impeach johnson we had a return of
that bad water and two or three senators
republicans mind you or prostrated with
southern sudden illness what does it
mean why does it happen that whenever
the current sets against the master
demon of slavery and never at any other
time we find the air and the water and
the whiskey of washington full of poison
that would be a great name for like a
bar by the way
the assassination theorists weren't the
only americans worried about
conspiracies of slave holders died
didn't coined the phrase slave power the
term was common currency in the north
uh where it was used to describe the
political influence of the planter elite
this was not in itself a conspiracy
theory but it often adopted a
conspiratorial coloring in the words of
the historian russell b nye the slave
power had an alleged agenda to extend
slavery to the territories and free
states possibly to whites and to destroy
civil liberties control the policies of
the federal government and complete the
formation of a nationwide ruling
aristocracy based on a slave economy
lincoln himself believed that he could
clearly see
a powerful plot to make slavery
universal and perpetual and in his
famous house divided speech he engaged
freely in conspiratorial speculation
senator henry wilson later to serve as
ulysses s grant's vice president put the
idea bluntly
slavery organized conspiracies in the
cabinet conspiracies in congress
conspiracies in the states conspiracies
in the army conspiracies in the navy
conspiracies everywhere for the
overthrow of the government in the
disruption of the republic
meanwhile southerners had elaborate
conspiracy theories of their own blaming
slave revolts both real and imagined on
the machinations of rebellion stoking
abolitionists treacherous land pirates
and other outside agitators
it was a paranoid time
in america it is always a paranoid time
so that's how the book begins i'm going
to tell you a bit about what else is in
it and then if i don't go too long at
that i'll read you a little bit more
basically
this is a history of political paranoia
in america and when i say paranoia i'm
using that word colloquially not
not clinically i think that um virtually
everyone is capable of uh thinking of
being a conspiracy theorist of political
paranoia and when i say everyone i
include you me and the founding fathers
um
i the first half of the book sets out
five recurring um and i should add also
the two sort of assumptions people have
made when they um hear about the book is
either that it's an attack on conspiracy
theorists or that i'm espousing all my
favorite conspiracy theories neither is
true i mean i'm frank about it if i
think a conspiracy theory is nonsense i
also discuss um some conspiracies that
genuinely did happen i mean they were i
have a chapter on the 1970s
investigations of the church committee
and so on um after watergate that
exposed various awful deeds of the cia
and fbi and so on
what i'm really interested in is the
stories
the stories that kept keep getting told
again and again
sometimes just they sound familiar to
just put some different names in them
and
what those stories say
because even when a conspiracy theory
says absolutely nothing true about the
objects of the theory it says something
true about the anxieties and experiences
of the people who believe it they're a
form of folklore and if they catch on
that's something that's worth paying
attention to
so the first half of the book
lays out sort of five primal archetypal
conspiracy stories that are told over
and over um i'll give you their names
you can inquire more about them in the
in the um
uh question and answer if you like
they're the enemy outside the enemy
within the enemy below the enemy above
and the benevolent conspiracy because
sometimes they're conspiracies that are
supposed to be the good guys
and then the second half of the book
looks at the last half century of
american history through the lens uh
with the toolkit of the first that i set
out in the first half of the book and
they're sort of from watergate to waco
to the war on terror
and um
i look along the ways at sort of the
rise of uh
of a sort of self-conscious conspiracy
subculture
also the rise of what i call the ironic
style of
conspiracy theorizing which is people
aren't so much interested in
either espousing or debunking a theory
but just having fun with it maybe
building one of their owns that says
something maybe looking at other peoples
and mining uh the sort of what sort of
laughs or metaphors or what have you
they can find there
and i also make sure to look at the
conspiracy theories of the establishment
which aren't always called conspiracy
theories but often when there's a moral
panic afoot
all sorts of conspiratorial notions are
taken very seriously in government in
the mass media i mean the most
extreme recent example would be the
satanic ritual abuse scare of the 1980s
and 90s but there are others as well and
oftentimes some something that
sounds like an is you know a fringe
theory in one decade can suddenly have a
version of it be promoted
by very central american institutions
mass media and so on in the next decade
and then fade again
so i mentioned the ironic style one
thing i at the end of the chapter on the
aaronic style
i uh talk about a couple of um
writers who
created such vivid um
conspiracies for fun that they wound up
sort of going down a rabbit hole and
believing them
themselves
one of them came back from that trip
around the band that's paul krasner who
edits the real edited the realist
writer worth reading
and the other who never came back from
around the bend was carrie thornley who
was a co-founder of a sort of a mock
religion called discordianism that was
supposed to worship eris the greek
goddess of chaos
was a big influence on the illuminatis
trilogy by robert shea and robert anton
wilson which is sort of a classic cult
novel sort of a perotic treatment of um
of conspiracy theories
um
and who also had the uh distinction of
serving in the marines with lee harvey
oswalt and uh when oswald defected to
the soviet union thornley thought this
was interesting and decided to write a
novel about him didn't get published uh
told many decades later but it's still
probably the only book written about
oswald before the kennedy assassination
so
jumping into the other section i'm going
to read
thornley managed to get drawn into the
jfk assassination circus jim garrison
y'all remember jim garrison he uh better
known i think is kevin costner these
days he was the
new orleans d.a who was investigating
the kennedy assassination in the 60s
jim garrison tried to get him involved
in his investigation of the kennedy
killing and after thornley rebuffed the
d.a garrison started suggesting that
thornley himself had been a part of the
plot
garrison put out a press release
claiming that the discordian had been
closely associated with lee oswalt not
just in the marines but at a number of
locations in new orleans in september
1963.
thornley gave a deposition before a new
orleans grand jury at the beginning of
1968 and the experience convinced him
that garrison's team wasn't interested
in justice among other things the team
members seemed intent on pigeonholing
him as a birch style conservative
i explained several times to them that i
am neither a traditionalist nor a
nationalist nor a racist that i oppose
the john birch society in what passes
today is political conservatism thornley
wrote shortly afterward i went on to say
that i am a right winger in so far as i
favor individualism but my rightism is
more anarchistic than authoritarian they
looked at me blankly not seeming to hear
as garrison's allegations spread through
the underground press thornley put out
his side of the story in every venue
available to him the subscribers to
ocean living a low circulation zine that
thornley helped edit were surely
surprised when the material they were
used to a typical article informed
readers that plankton can be gathered in
nets and used as a nourishing foodstuff
was now mixed with statements by
assassination theorists criticizing a
garrison for his pursuit of thornley
garrison was soon spreading the story
that thornley who bore some physical
resemblance to his marine friend had
served as a double for the accused
assassin posing as oswald in the time
before the president's murder so as to
create a false trail of oswald's
activities
as he fended off garrison's attacks
thornley reconsidered his assumption
that oswald had acted alone in dallas in
1973 he read a feature in the yippie
tabloid yipster times that would be
later be expanded into canfield and
weberman's book coup d'etat in america
thornley wasn't just convinced he began
to suspect that he really had been
involved in the assassination without
his knowledge
a hypnotized zombie held in reserve in
case something went wrong with the
oswald plan he started typing up his
speculations boosted by new memories of
things that he believed had happened to
him years before and he circulated the
manuscripts among his contacts after
that he perceived various odd events as
the secret government's reactions to
those memorandums
some of the incidents would scare anyone
at one point armed bandits and ski masks
had raided a party he was attending
stealing thornley's identification along
with everyone else's money but thornley
was also capable of accusing his
girlfriend of working for the conspiracy
he wrote to greg hill greg hill being
the other founder of discordanism he
wrote to greg hill i am literally
surrounded by the intelligence community
that's back when literally meant
literally by the way so
i am literally surrounded by the
intelligence community but after the
first three attempts to murder me things
seem to have cooled down and most of the
spies now appear to be on my side
at one point he became convinced that a
co-worker at the sunshine floral company
was really robert anton wilson living
incognito with timothy leary in atlanta
for reasons i obviously could not fathom
he wondered whether the collapse of the
new left was caused by foreign
intelligence agencies dosing organizers
with a substance causing heart disease
thereafter maintaining control over them
by means of a microwave device capable
of instantly halting a pacemaker
by the 1990s he believed that he was the
the product of a variable society
breeding slash environmental
manipulation experiment
in the midst of this the real wilson cut
off his correspondence with thornley it
was hard he told adam go rightly years
later to communicate with somebody when
he thinks you're a diabolical mind
control agent and you're convinced that
he's a little bit paranoid
thornley continued to write sometimes
with wit and self-awareness sometimes
not
he spent the last few years of his life
working at menial jobs in atlanta and
selling trinkets and essays on the
street it was a chaotic conclusion to a
chaotic life a darkly poetic fate i
suppose for a man who worshipped eris
you know thornley told hill in one of
his more lucid moments if i had realized
all of this was going to come true i
would have chosen venus
[Music]
so it's almost 7 30 should we have
questions now
all right
questions accusations applause yeah yeah
yes could you tell us what motivated you
to write on this on this topic um it was
a payoff by uh
now i um
you know i've um
i started reading sort of conspiracy
theories in my teens actually reading
those sort of serious exposes of the cia
the fbi and so on that came out
following
the church committee reports and so on
and often they were on the same shelves
i found those books that were not quite
as reliable um
but often fun to read
and around the same time also um
i discovered things like you know the
illuminatis trilogy the church of the
subgenius the whole ironic style and
this whole sort of subculture of people
who could appreciate commit um
conspiracy theories without necessarily
believing all of them or going all the
way all the way constantly into you know
the freak out that someone believes
something that isn't true
um so that's the uh that was the the
origins of the interest i
this book um
it i mean i wrote it in uh the last few
years but i draw on interviews i did as
a journalist in the middle of the 90s
you know covering stuff about the
militia movement and their uh unexpected
intersection with black nationalists and
so on often around conspiracy theories
so i've had a um i've had a long time of
writing about this to build on
thank you sir
if i read your mind correctly you leave
the impression that all
of the american public is subject to a
degree of paranoia
and can be unconsciously developing
conspiracy theories
is this partially what you're saying
yeah i mean i i try not to use um 100
words like all you know there's always
there's always someone then who could
stand up and say or or be in a coma or
something and therefore not be having a
conspiracy theory but i i think that
there
there's three things that kind of go
into i hate to make any reductive
explanation of where conspiracy theories
come from because they come from all
kinds of places and it's not like
there's a particular type of person who
is you know susceptible or whatever um
and i i but um there's three things that
are sort of all going on uh one is that
we naturally seek patterns we naturally
create narratives tell stories that's
how we make sense of the world
we organize things into stories number
two we constantly have things to be
afraid of um and gaps in our knowledge
that we're then creating stories about
uh to explain the world that makes you
prone to conspiracy theories that
combination when you throw on the fact
that sometimes people really do conspire
it's not like being afraid of you know
werewolves or um sea monsters that you
know you can actually um point to
cointelpro and say well that one
happened i i mean the the chapter about
the um 1970s investigations part of it
is going on about um
what actually happened i mean the actual
uh
bona fide conspiratorial behavior but
also talking about how that kind of
lowered the bar for what people were
willing to believe um
i mean once you've heard
that the cia did this you start to
imagine maybe the cia did that
and then when it starts going into pop
culture and we get all those great
movies that came out around that time
that in turn also influences the way
people form their narratives so
um i hope that answered the question
sure all right question for a conspiracy
theory to spread of course it has to be
picked up and done so i'm wondering what
your thoughts are about the internet it
makes it so easy now to spread maybe
easier than ever is that going to be
it's also can be corrected but does the
internet have an or do you see the
internet
having an impact in the future on
conspiracy theories now and as i say in
the future also yeah and not so much on
the quantity as in the velocity with
which they spread and also the ways they
mix i mean and really in the 1990s
particularly this had been building
before the 90s but
um in the 90s there was this sort of
golden age of um
of you know
the militiamen and the hippies and the
black nationalists and the ufo guys they
were all reading each other's stuff
and you could have all sorts of uh odd
combinations or what might seem at first
to be odd combinations um emerge
and that has only intensified since then
what's the difference between just kind
of or what makes a difference between
just misinformation
and a conspiracy theory
well um
two things there's a lot of
misinformation they don't all become
blown up in and i'm thinking about like
the death panels with obamacare yeah you
know and i actually um
i struggled with whether or not it was
right to describe um death penals as a
conspiracy theory in this and i think i
did i mean because they do have that
conspiratorial image of people in a room
condemning people to death um
but i um
yeah i so your question is like where do
you draw the line between what i mean i
guess you draw the line at the point
where someone invokes a conspiracy you
know i i mean it's i mean one thing that
bother there's two things that bother me
about the way the phrase conspiracy
conspiracy three theory gets thrown
around one is as i said that um if
they're
embraced by
major social institutions or a lot of
people they're not considered conspiracy
theories or at least not until it's in
retrospect
um usually and the other is oftentimes
just anything that um challenges uh
dominant social institutions or the
conventional wisdom gets called a conv
kind of conspiracy theory even if
there's no conspiracy involved i uh some
say i think it was mother jones recently
had like a top nine conspiracy theories
about obamacare and i think maybe two of
them actually involved conspiracies they
were just you know
wanting to you know mock these ideas by
calling them conspiracy theories but
most of them weren't
um i don't know does that sort of dance
around answering your question yeah
that's right tricky
i can agree with you that it seems like
americans are
especially subject to uh conspiracy
i say i can uh see that
it's easy to imagine that americans are
um
especially susceptible to conspiracy
theories but is there any hard evidence
that that's true in comparison to uh
other countries
any quantitative information i don't
claim that it's true i mean i i say at
the beginning that um i'm talking about
americans because this is a this is me
looking at american history through the
prism of you know the things people have
been afraid of um but obviously i mean
for all i know the french are scared to
death of everything you know i i i i i i
don't i mean it's clearly you know
russia middle east many countries you
hear about conspiracy theories although
i assume
um that the dominant um
that i mean they the style is going to
differ from culture to culture um but
the only sort of conspiracy stories from
abroad that i cover are the ones that
had influence in the in america
so but i'm not making a quantitative
claim
you've yielded to a uh
american tradition which is to kind of
minimize
our relations with latin america
and latin america as you probably know
you perhaps know is
full of
ideas of everything practically
everything the united states does
there's a cia conspiracy behind it
but uh to me the lulu of this was i was
attending a meeting at the johnson
library
and ran into um
he had been um
who was it donnie
the he was a
he was in the cabinet he was secretary
of the cabinet of johnson
anyway we'll call him mr x
mr x said
uh
you don't realize
that castro
was getting ready to kill kennedy
well as a matter of fact i had
interviewed castro many times and if
there was anything he had been looking
forward
to kennedy coming into the
administration as a matter of
generational understanding he said that
it was impossible for eisenhower to
understand where he came from because i
i just now belong to another generation
but kennedy who was coming at at that
time
kennedy was about to to to take office
had already been elected
and he said
uh i i'm i'm very hopeful
and this was an official interview i was
taking notes for five hours
and
and he said and i i was he said well i'm
i'm looking forward of of an improved
relationship
and i was ready i was leaving and he
called me back
but they will not let him and they of
course was what eisenhower called the
military something establishment
thank you
[Music]
do you talk anything about like economic
conspiracies and uh
you know the gnomes of zurich and
people ascribing
things to forces beyond their control
it's it bedevils people i think these
days and uh surely there must be a
conspiracy there yeah sure i mean i mean
obviously um i mean in fact the
the chapter on the enemy above you know
i'm part of what i trace in there is
sort of the
um this isn't the gnomes of zurich but
the evolution of sort of always seeing
um the enemy above as being in or trying
to capture the state you know or i mean
if not in the states and in a secret
society trying to seize the state and
gradually that sort of expanding to
include you know corporations first
things like the uh the bank of the
second bank of the united states which
was a creature of the state and
railroads which were subsidized by the
state and gradually just all you know
the trusts and so on so yeah i mean
there's there's all sorts of economic
related uh conspiracy thinking in here
so
yeah thank you this is a fascinating
topic
but
but overall and i want to stay with you
on this higher
plane what do you do about conspiracy
theories that so divide our country when
we have
no institution with the credibility
to address and
resolve
these competing
views of reality and i'll just take the
911.
you know there's the government case
and then there's the architects and
engineers case which says that the
government's case is
not possible under the laws of physics
so
you know that's that's pretty compelling
dispute
um
what do we do when
when faced with conspiracy theories that
are incredibly divisive
um
well i there's there's a few things in
there to unpack um
i mean as far as
i don't think i mean conspiracy theories
can be divisive but um
they're also a product of divisions
right i mean social divisions are
kind of inevitable although sometimes
you can have more than others and that's
part of what produces uh conspiracy
theories or conspiracy suspicions is
wondering what's going on in you know
the other faction you know
um
so i and of course then they turn around
and reinforce it but i um i don't think
there's like some magic bullet that can
end
social divisiveness um and and i think
that there's always going to be you know
joining wine um
debates over the proper direction for
the uh for the country and and so i
wouldn't want to eliminate all
divisiveness you need to have um
it's kind of
yeah
anyone else
nope
oh yeah um
yeah the enemy outside i mean they're
kind of self-explanatory but the enemy
outside is um
i mean the two classic models of it that
are the fear of the native americans
native american conspiracies um and the
fear of the um
uh the roman catholic church and while
the uh the indians were sort of seen as
this kind of
unruly anarchistic um
alternative or sort of threat and the
the church was seen as sort of the uh
aristocratic old world trying to
reimpose its its hierarchies there were
of course all sorts of imagined uh on
taunts between the you know catholics
and indians um
so but so i mean that the enemy uh
within uh well i'll come back to that
one the enemy um above is the
conspirators at the top of the social uh
hierarchy enemy below is the fear of
people at the bottom of the social
hierarchy um because people in power
have conspiracy theories too i get into
um
a discussion of uh
in particular i talk a lot about um
fears of slave revolts um and historians
often have a very hard time looking back
and telling which slave revolts actually
happened and which were just slave
owners freaking out because they saw
people talking and then brutally
cracking down
um
the enemy within is someone who's not
easily
identified by where they're from or
their social status or their ethnic or
racial background as a possible agent of
the conspiracy the enemy within is the
neighbor co-worker even someone in your
family who might be one of the pod
people right it's uh and then the
benevolent conspiracy is sort of working
behind the scenes to make life better
um
it's uh it would include people who have
these great
visions of rosicrucians you know
founding america in secret and trying to
create a higher destiny also a lot of
um uh ex uh the benevolent
extraterrestrials uh the angel fed of
the 1990s
um you know i mean in a lot of ways um
ufo uh people
sort of secularized old ideas about uh
higher powers and then the angel folks
then resacralized that that sort of drew
on that um
that body of of storytelling
i wonder if you could take a few minutes
and walk us through the kennedy
assassination the war and report the
conspiracy theories that were
prevalent then and maybe the conspiracy
theories that are prevalent now
a few minutes you say
yeah
yeah
i i am
i'll say i mean the kennedy
assassination is one of those things i
mean you heard in the carrie thornley
section it keeps popping up i don't have
like a chapter devoted to it or anything
like that but what um what i will say
about it is that and and setting aside
questions about you know i'm obviously
one thing that drives is people saying
here anomalies i want to investigate it
i don't buy what the warren commission
says i want to so i don't want to just
psychologize the entire thing people can
have
um questions um based on their reading
of the evidence but
use nonetheless i noticed that the um
conspiracy theories or or even sometimes
as other forms of paranoia that aren't
conspiracies don't involve conspiracies
um that catch on at different times in
reaction to the kennedy assassination
parallels other fears going on in
society at that time so that in 1963
on the one hand the president is shot in
dallas there's this sort of big fear of
the radical right at that time lots of
people worried about the minutemen the
john birch society and so on there's
this instant assumption that oswald must
be an agent of the radical right or or a
member of it and then it comes out that
he um
defected to the soviet union for a while
had activism or sort of pro-cuban
activism um as conspiracy theorists will
say appear to be pro-cuban activism um
and so that fed into cold war fears and
there was the natural sort of
anti-communist conspiracy theories
there's as the new left built there is
more and more uh fears that maybe the
government was in on it and then in the
70s with the post-watergate
investigation that breaks through you
know there's a wave of books talking
about me this blaming the cia the fbi
and so on even as late as uh the first
bush administration hw um there were
people who were
saying well he was in the cia before we
knew he was in the cia and he was
involved with it um i mentioned paul
krasner actually this is not in the book
but he continued in the realist to
publish
conspiracy investigations along with
joking conspiracy investigations and not
labeling which were which and he
ran a piece by someone who actually
fabricated some stuff trying to
implicate um bush bush senior in the
kennedy assassination and then
um was uh and then ran like a notice
saying that you know this guy you know
lied to me he claimed this was there
that wasn't there and i asked him you
know well did you since you're famous
for having a a magazine that doesn't
maple what's journalism or what satire
did you just sort of move this from one
category to the other now in retrospect
no no i was just livid um
so i mean so that's i mean of course
what i just said can't cover everything
i mean the mafia theories are in
evergreen and so on but i do think that
um
that's one way of sort of looking at the
kennedy assassination through history
so
another question
yeah um one question about maybe um
the
the intersection of conspiracy theories
and say investigative journalism you
know we hear
so much more i'd say within the last you
know 10 years
about the freedom of information act and
you know i it seems like there's there's
a much greater awareness of
the idea that oh yeah after a certain
period of time
such and such documents will be released
in some form or another and you know
we've seen a few noteworthy incidents
where uh
where where some pretty serious
information did come to pass um
when when the documents were were
released have you have you seen sort of
a
any trends that are
emerging you know in terms of
maybe these aren't things that have
become big enough to become full-blown
conspiracies that but within maybe that
certain community of people who are
actually doing the investigation well i
mean investigative journalists i mean
often they're
exposing or seeking to expose you know
legitimate conspiracies that exist so
and often um if someone is denigrating
an investigative journalist work they
will say ah conspiracy theory and often
if someone is maybe a bit on the nutty
side they could still try to dignify
what they're doing with the phrase
investigative journalism um but you know
there's uh just as there are conspiracy
theories that are true and some that
aren't there's good investigative
journalism embed investigative
journalism you mentioned foias um i
actually had um a foia put in on someone
i write about in this book come through
as i um as i was uh
checking the proofs i had to add stuff
um it's it's become not in that case but
it's it's become actually more difficult
to foia a lot in the in the last decade
so if anything i think the sort of
movement is away from although the flip
side is it's so much easier to find
stuff online i don't remember who
mentioned the internet but it was so
great for my my purposes to be able to
just go to fbi.gov and download all
these cointelpro
documents that they've made available um
or you mentioned archive.org by the way
i mean it is so much easier to write a
book when there's archive.org with all
sorts of wonderful old
entire books uh you know about the
puritans that were published hundreds of
years ago now up there on um go to
archive.org everyone um
so
and and i i'm sorry i gave a commercial
and i forgot if i answered your question
but hopefully i yeah
you uh you mentioned at the beginning of
the talk how america has always been a
conspiratorial nation a paranoid people
um and i was sort of put in mind of the
great reason tv video i think it was
2010 talking about vitriol and politics
are we
criticizing each other too harshly are
we just is it just you know a shouting
match etc etc and uh the video pointed
out that back in you know 1800 or
whatever it was even more vitriolic and
people were calling each other even more
names and so i'm wondering if the
conspiracy theories you saw towards the
beginning of american history were more
outrageous or less credible or anything
like that well i i won't try to quantify
it but i mean if you want to hear about
um
i mean the jeffersonians and the
federalists had such
uh complicated conspiracy theories about
and vitriolic ones about each other um
and there was one at john adams's
administration
um
he planned to unite his family with the
royal house of great britain the
bridegroom to be king of america
yeah it's a it it's there certainly was
no shortage of that sort of vitriolic um
yeah and one would like to think that
you know the rise of education et cetera
et cetera would have damp like dampen
that a little bit but perhaps not well i
i i don't know i mean it's it's not like
people were that they were writing
pamphlets were ill-educated at that
point you know i mean it's very uh
well-educated people true
uh recently there's been release of
government uh archives that uh
substantiate uh conspiracy theories that
or you might say the people basically
knew to be true over the years about the
cia fomenting the uh uh the overthrow of
deck
also sort of saying well area 51 does
exist do you
not that i'm trying to start a new
conspiracy
theory but uh do you see any reason why
these uh things are happening and do you
think there's any attempt to sort of uh
uh
get attention away from
prism and
i i don't know why the uh why the cia
just chose this moment to um reveal it
um
and they may well have said why they did
it i just have i just read the headline
you know i didn't read all of the
stories so
um
i i don't know what the source of these
reasons i mean i will say that it's um
the british government actually sort of
at regular intervals you know releases
old documents and sometimes there's some
pretty amazing um there's one in there
this of course is not in the book
because it's british
and i'm hoping i'm remembering it right
but there was um there was a ufo
cover-up
that was
it was not they were covering up the
existence of ufos like they were
covering up their failure to spot any or
something i don't know i i shouldn't be
saying this extemporaneously but it was
it was like this great a sort of moment
of bureaucratic ass covering that can
spiral into all sorts of uh
suspicions later
anyone
so the last sentence has ass in it
apparently
that
c-span you know
yeah
i should have insisted you call me the
honorable speaker while i was here i'm
uh
i am
all right i guess that's it
thank you
[Applause]
is there a non-fiction author or book
you'd like to see featured on book